one of the most interesting parts of the
entire technology industry is how much
it relies on interest rates what do i
mean well most people would think that
the mainstream narrative the consensus
view of the world is that when interest
rates go down then risk assets go up in
price
you can think of tech stocks and things
like bitcoin or cryptocurrencies as risk
assets so of course when there's cheap
capital because interest rates have gone
down those assets go up in price people
put risk on but if all of a sudden
central banks around the world started
to raise interest rates the prevailing
logic would be that risk assets would
sell off that if interest rates go up
tech stocks bitcoin cryptocurrencies etc
will sell down now we've seen this play
out before as we have here keith's boy
the other day pointed out perfectly
saying it's amazing many journalists and
people in tech don't appear to know that
the proximate cause of the internet
bubble collapsing was greenspan and the
fed raising interest rates now of course
that has happened in the past history
does not necessarily repeat but it does
rhyme and so he went on to say that his
prediction is that the tech market will
collapse no later than the second
interest rate hike by the fed and so
again this is looking forward we don't
yet know what exactly is going to happen
but i think that most people would
generally agree that when interest rates
are
increased
risk assets go down now what is
fascinating though is that we have caleb
franzen who has come forward and said
look the correlation between bitcoin and
the 10-year treasuries since mid-2020 is
uncanny there's a perfect overlap and
these quantitative relationships aren't
being discussed for the bull run to
continue will rates need to rise further
now to be clear somebody like a keith
o'boy has specifically talked about
tech stocks selling off and he's clearly
caught up because i don't know what's
gonna happen with bitcoin that is a big
question in some ways it may serve as a
hedge and what we see here is that
bitcoin's price is actually moving in
lockstep with treasury yields now if we
continue and we look what he goes and he
talks about is that the correlation is
extremely unique and not what we would
expect to see in risk assets we
typically expect to see an inverse
correlation between risk assets and
yields for example if we look at arc or
the inverse tnx on a year-to-date basis
they get a perfect correlation
this is normal risk assets moving
inversely to yields if we go ahead and
we look at the actual tech stocks
themselves what we can see as an example
of a normal correlation the dynamic
between the nasdaq 100 futures and the
10-year treasury yields you can see that
the present value of tech stocks has an
inverse correlation to yields exactly
what you would expect to see as yields
go up risk assets go down as yields go
down risk assets go up this inverse
correlation the opposite reaction ends
up being what you would expect between
risk assets and yields but if we go and
we look well he clearly calls out his
perspective and almost all other bitcoin
bulls was that low rates and monetary
stimulus were extremely bullish for
bitcoin now we must confront the idea
that higher nominal rates are positive
with ongoing tapering and liftoff
expected in 2022 is this bullish and he
says more than anything else this might
be proof positive that bitcoin is
working as a hedge against inflation if
inflation continues to surge in 2022
anticipated actions by the fed to speed
up the taper and liftoff process will
likely cause rates to move higher and
faster and then he goes on to say that
the net present value formula teaches us
that all else being equal you have that
inverse relationship yields go up asset
prices go down
however
big big however based on the correlation
between bitcoin and treasury yields it
appears that we may see we might see
yields go up bitcoin go up yields go up
bitcoin go up that would be breaking
from the legacy consensus and so
ultimately when i saw this what i
started to think to myself was why would
this be true and what i have concluded
is that in an environment where rates or
yields are going up people are actually
being incentivized to go back out of the
risk assets go back to value investments
go back to conservative assets like the
dollar or these bonds and so ultimately
if bitcoin is actually the reserve
currency of this new digital financial
system then bitcoin would be acting
similar to a dollar or to one of these
types of bonds and so in some crazy
crazy way although the legacy finance
folks look at bitcoin as a risk-on asset
they believe that it is similar to a
technology stock it is part of the most
asymmetric part of their portfolio
in the crypto industry where a majority
of young people hold a very material
part of their net worth they think of
this as their financial system
bitcoin is actually the flight to safety
it's the most conservative asset it's
the thing that if you're gonna go back
into safety
bitcoin can be one of those solutions
now it's not the only one there's things
like stable coins and others
but
it is very very interesting and it
breaks the narrative that risk assets
would go down if yields go up because
right now when yield goes up bitcoin
goes up and so if the fed was to
actually go ahead and increase interest
rates in 2022 they've signaled that
there would be three potential interest
rate increases if that was to happen and
bitcoin went up i think it would leave a
lot of people scratching their head i
don't know what's going to happen i
don't think anyone knows what's going to
happen but i do think that it's
important to visit these types of
analysis because it is exactly opposite
of what the mainstream consensus view is
so time will tell when yields go up and
the fed decides to act will bitcoin go
up or will it go down and i think that
right now the most important number in
all of finance is what is that interest
rate environment are they going to raise
the rates or are they not time's going
to tell what bitcoin's reaction will be
as well